♪ -Hashtags ♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#WhyImSingle stories
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one's
from @RickyP3rd.
He says, "I took a girl to
the movies for our first date.
She leaned in for a kiss,
so I leaned in too,
but then I accidentally sneezed
in her face."
[ Audience awws ]
-RickyP3rd.
-Yeah.
This one's from @SweatyBetty.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, there you go.
-No, that's not the reason.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
-That's not the reason
why she's single.
No.
She says, "I once walked into
a guy's really messy apartment
and said, 'Oh, cool!
This is just like one of
those places
in the Febreze commercials.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughs ] What?
This one is from
@tidewoddergirl.
She says,
"I was on a great blind date.
When I returned
from the restroom,
I sat down and resumed talking.
I got a confused look,
then a voice behind me said,
'You're at the wrong table.
I'm over here.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I like this.
-My eyes!
This...
This one's from @keirstinyo.
-Yo!
-She says, "I once dated a girl
who had the same name as my ex,
but one time
I accidentally slipped up
and called her New Brittany
to her face."
[ Laughter ]
What?
-"New Brittany."
-The new --
You're New Brittany. Oh, gosh.
-Oops. You did it again.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from
@ninjamandr1221.
He says, "Whenever I watch
a movie, I turn my hoodie around
and use it as a bowl
for my popcorn."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's kind of brilliant.
-Genius.
-That's kind of genius.
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ] God.
-Like a trough.
-Yeah, I love it.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
This one's from
@itsShyyyyyyyyyy.
She says,
"A guy I liked said, 'Date?'
and I immediately said yes.
He was asking me
what day it was."
He's like, "No,
do you have the date?"
-No.
-Do you have the date?
Oh, God.
-"Date." Oof.
This last one's from
@GrandpaBerty.
-Ohh.
-She says, "A boy picked me
a flower once.
I panicked and ate it."
Oh, there you go. Oh, my God.
Those are our "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
-Here are some of my favorite
#MySiblingIsWeird tweets
from you guys. Here we go.
This first one's
from @aberlean.
She says,
"My sister watches 'Dateline'
to make sure her husband
isn't living a double life."
[ Laughter ]
-She thinks she's gonna
catch him on that episode?
-They had the perfect marriage.
Or did they?
-He was living a double life.
-It was a fun cruise.
[ Laughter ]
-Until they discovered --
-Until they discovered
the first deck.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @missgreenwalt.
She says, "My sister made
a secret handshake with me
so we could test each other
in case one of us
was ever replaced by an alien."
-Is that weird or smart?
-That makes sense.
It's smart. It's not weird.
It's smart. Yeah, you're right.
-Bleep-blurp!
-This one's from --
[ Laughter ]
Bleep Blurp was, what, an alien?
-That's what aliens say.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think so.
This one's from @robindechant.
She says,
"My brother would eat the bodies
of chocolate bunnies,
but not the heads.
He hid the heads under his bed."
[ Laughter and applause ]
On an all-new "Dateline."
-Under his bed was a thousand...
[ Laughter ]
...bunny heads.
-Yeah, some chocolate,
some real.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @bailliepaige.
She says, "Each time my sister
got a new stuffed animal,
she had to have a town hall
and introduce it to each
of her other animals."
[ Laughter ]
-She's 38.
-She's 38 years old.
This one's from @brettadkison.
He says, "Read my sister's diary
once. First entry said,
'Dear Diary, I just stole you
from the store.'"
[ Laughter ]
It's honest, man.
-God bless her.
-This one's from @jimmyshadwick.
He says, "My little brother once
dressed up like Spider-Man,
put Elmer's glue in his hands
and tried to climb up the wall."
[ Laughter ]
You just gave away
his secret identity.
-Elmer's glue.
-Oh, this is a good one.
This one's from @mmharter.
She says, "My brother
used to think
Mount Rushmore was carved
that way by the wind."
[ Laughter ]
-How weird!
It looks like
all those presidents, man.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @godiyperry.
She says, "My brother
told me old people are wrinkly
because they're slowly
being sucked to hell."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-In some cases.
-That can't be right.
-No, I don't think that's true.
That's probably not true.
-No. This last one
is from @wespace.
He says, "During a road trip,
my younger sister
loudly passed gas.
My mom yelled,
'What do you say?'
Embarrassed, she said, 'Ta-da?'"
[ Laughter ]
Ta-da?
Those are our "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MyDumbFight tweets
from you guys. Here we go.
This first one's
from @codymorrison32.
He says,
"I got into a fight with my dad
because he insisted the phrase
'my bad' was 'my bag.'"
[ Laughter ]
It's my bag!
-My bag, man.
-It's "my bad," Dad.
[ Laughter ]
What are you, a rapper now?
My bad, Dad. Rad.
This one's from @doublechili.
He says, "My parents
once fought over
who makes louder chewing noises.
My dad got out a loaf of bread
and said, 'Let's settle this.'"
[ Laughter ]
What?
-I don't think it was about --
-That's a ridiculous fight.
Settling it.
-"Let's settle this right now."
-"Let's do it right now.
Put this piece of bread
in your mouth."
-"I can't even hear you
chewing!"
[ Laughter ]
-"Sike! My bag!"
"I chew loud!"
You're also talking very loud.
"Let's settle this right now!"
-"With our bread!"
-This one's from --
-"It's my bag of bread!"
[ Laughter ]
-"This bread went bad."
-"No, it's bread went bag."
-"No, the bag of bread is bad!"
-"No, it's bad! Not bag!"
-"Let's settle this right now!
You eat the whole thing
of bread!"
This one's from @amandaking727.
She says, "My friend and I
were outside making our shadows
look like they were fighting,
and I accidentally punched her
in the face."
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, look, your shadow's
on the ground, bleeding."
-"Oh, my God,
my shadow's bleeding."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @thetruenewfie.
He says, "During an argument
with my friend,
I forgot to invite him
to my party.
So he said, well,
I'm going to throw a party
and nobody is invited."
[ Laughter ]
Alright, you're cool, man.
Take care.
Let me know how it goes
or don't. Or don't.
This one's from @zevin27.
He says, "My friend and I argued
about who would be
hotter as a girl."
[ Laughter ]
"Are you kidding me, bro?
Look at my calves,
how supple they are.
-"Look at this nose."
-This one's from @thepetelife.
He says, "My wife and I
got in an argument
over whether Mickey and Minnie
were married or just dating."
[ Laughter ]
I actually found out
the truth of this.
You guys went some trivia?
What do you think? Married?
-Yes.
-No, don't show --
A round of applause.
I can't see your hands.
[ Laughter ]
Round of applause. Married?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Round of applause, dating.
Ready?
[ Drumroll ]
Walt Disney said they are
married in their personal life.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In their personal life.
So what he's saying is that
everything we're seeing
are movies that the actors
Mickey and Minnie are in.
[ Laughter ]
-So they're dating --
They're dating on the screen.
But in their personal life,
they're married?
They're like Burns and Allen.
-Yeah, it's like -- it's like --
Yeah, it's like Lucy and --
Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah. And Desi Arnaz.
-So they're married off camera.
-Off camera, yes,
they're a married couple
that work in the business.
[ Laughter ]
And then when we see them, they
could be dating, could be not.
I mean, this is
just insane to me.
It just ruined
my whole childhood.
I'm like, "Wait, so Mickey
isn't a magician?"
Like, "No, he's an actor."
-"He's an actor pretending
to play different roles."
He's not the helper
of a magician.
-He's a mouse,
a cute mouse who talks.
This last one's
from @lwilliams128.
[ Woman cheers ]
She says --
Is that you?
-That's me!
[ Laughter ]
-For real?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah! Come on! Get out here!
-Hey, welcome to the show.
[ Laughter ]
-Is she gonna read it?
-Yeah, come over here.
Come on, read it.
I don't care.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi.
Come on up.
-Hi.
-Hi. Nice to meet you.
-Have a seat there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, this is LWilliams128.
That's you?
-That's me.
-That's you.
-Yeah.
-Well, thank you for sending in
and playing the hashtag game.
-My pleasure.
-Yeah, cool.
[ Laughter ]
What does the L stand for?
-My first name.
-I thought that.
Yeah, I thought that.
-It's Lauren.
-Lauren.
-Yes.
-Lauren Williams. Okay, 128.
Why 128?
-It's something
that Gmail generated like,
"Hey, Lauren's taken.
Do you want this?"
It's like, "Yeah."
-Oh, interesting, okay.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, well,
I thought this was great.
It says, "My dumb fight
was about my dog's name.
Boyfriend wanted
something funny.
I wanted something awesome.
We settled on..."
-Tom Hanks.
-There you go. That's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's awesome and funny!
-Middle name.
-He's the best.
Thank you very much.
-Thank you so much.
-There you have it. Those are
"Tonight Show" hashtags.